cardi b is taking her love for
motherhood to a new level
by contemplating getting her son's name
tattooed on her face the up rapper took
to twitter sunday night writing quote
random but i'm one percent close to
chatting my son's name on my face i
really really want to do it they don't
know how much like that means to me
though cardi and her husband offset
welcomed their baby boy in september but
have yet to reveal his name if she
decides to commit to the new inc what an
epic name reveal that would be
[Laughter]
that's
you know what i'm saying cardi's tweet
comes after the 29 year old shared this
video of offset spending time with their
baby boy she captioned the video quote
he being mean to me he want to be with
his daddy shortly after that cardi gave
an update on their newborn who she says
hasn't been on his best behavior
today this one right here
has not been a good boy
first uh he woke up i think like one
hour earlier than you usually do and
although many would consider that
typical for babies something that isn't
typical is what the emcee revealed on
her son's four-month birthday i'm not
exaggerating
this baby is talking
i i put this on everything i love in the
name of jesus christ like first of all
my husband saw it um
yesterday i was like you love mommy yeah
come again you love mommy and he replied
back like yeah like not even like
it was like yeah she went on to share
that her son also said the word hello
while watching the kids show coco melon
yo this is crazy
i don't know if that's like the pandemic
thing i don't know if like this is
normal
this [ __ ] is crazy like i need a i need
a camera in this room 24 7 or something
because
yo you talking well in addition to
keeping their son's name a secret the
invasion of privacy rapper and offset
who are also parents to three-year-old
culture have yet to show his face
while we wait for the big reveal here's
what cardi told et in 2019 about
motherhood following the birth of her
daughter culture
what does it mean to be a mother it
means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's indescribable
it's like
like
love joy it's a switch
you know what i'm saying it's like an
automatic smile right it's automatic
worries
sad you know what i'm saying like it's
like you know my baby had a cold
and
i never felt like like so sad and i
wanted to cry and
so worried like i just
oh god it's crazy so it's everything
everything yeah she means everything to
you yes and i think i mean i mean
everything to her like i said when i she
sees me she kicks her feet so fast it's
like she loves me